disbelief and joy at the opposition
headquarters in the state of marinas
people celebrated until late at night
the victory of the opposition candidate
over that of the ruling socialist party
in the home state of venezuela's former
president tugo chavez
newly elected governor sergio garrido
said marinas made history on sunday
the world has its eyes on berinas and we
can show with strength and unity what we
have achieved we surpassed adversity in
spite of the obstacles we encountered i
want to recognize the brave people of
barinas
the ruling socialist party won in most
state during local elections last
november but this is the second time
people headed to the polls to elect
local authorities in marinas after
another opposition candidate was
disqualified by the country's highest
court and the rerun was announced for
january 9th
marinas is a crucial state for the
socialist party it's the birthplace of
hugo chavez and has been run by his
family for over 20 years
the maduro government picked former
foreign minister jorge ryaza as the
socialist candidate and deployed more
than 24 000 security personnel to secure
the elections
people in venezuela are going through a
devastating economic crisis
5 million people have left the country
and most of those who've stayed are
struggling with inflation and poverty
we're fighting not just for a change in
governor but also for a fundamental
change in barina society in venezuelan
society after the death of commander
chavez things have become chaotic
the government of nicolas maduro is
under pressure by the international
community to guarantee free elections
analysts say sunday's vote could be a
turning point
the government has invested so much in
this election all their power was in
ballinas losing it could inspire voters
to go to the opposition who stopped
believing that through elections there
could be change and we're years away
from the presidential elections but this
may definitely help them in the years
ahead
for the opposition the result is a
significant victory
but it's still a long way from winning
the presidential seat
teresa